it's Friday and that means it's time for
the viral app makes privacy a thing of
the past
an astronaut sends a protester to the
moon and another American flag under
attack joining us with all the details
Raymond Arroyo Fox News contributor and
New York Times bestselling author
Raymond Arroyo tell us about this new
viral app that has everyone horrified
and the possible dangers Lord look
celebrities have made this thing explode
it's called face app it's a sensation it
takes a picture match your face and then
ages you up or down everyone from Mario
Lopez to the Jonas Brothers to Mindy
Kaling have posted pictures of their
geriatric selves the face of help is now
a bestseller on the Apple Store here is
the problem users have to download the
app and upload personal pictures to it
now all that data is reportedly stored
on Russian servers and shared with
companies like Facebook and Google
Senator Chuck Schumer is asked for an
investigation citing privacy concerns
and the Democratic National Committee
has warned campaigns to immediately
delete the app their word Laura there
there's cause for concern you authorize
when you download the app every photo on
your device this app has accessed you
that's what you authorized and it's an
irrevocable non-exclusive royalty-free
license I read the Terms of privacy
this is like a Twilight Zone episode
where the you know the whole town takes
part in something sowing the seeds of
their doom I don't like it I don't like
it at all okay let me just say that
Raymond someone sent Raymond the the
aged face yes but we're not showing now
oh but I said I said ever even where's
your aides for he was so funny
well I don't know a friend of mine did
upload this picture of me and it came
back as an arroyo embryo look at that I
never looked like that no I look like a
Disney character what character no you
look pissed at me the same anyway of
course Raymond Raymond doesn't one
makes them look younger what do you
think I'm crazy yeah the staff and I
submitted a picture of you Lord here's
the picture we submitted of you and it
came back aged a few years up though the
hairstyle just aged naturally why do we
need a preview of how bad we're gonna
look if you're all if you're lucky
enough to get old
embrace it that's what I say yeah people
have way too much time on their hands
I'm a tree I first of all when you
download an app you always have to put
your Apple ID in and I've changed that
like at least once a day
now some always like make it a good
password I have to share this with you
this week we commemorated the 50th
anniversary of the Apollo 11 moon
landing Buzz Aldrin who along with Neil
Armstrong were the first men to walk on
the moon surface commemorated the moment
this way on July 16 1969 by my greatest
good fortune I was able to join Neil and
Mike on the Saturn 5 that day now I look
forward to America's leading role in a
next step Space Alliance Buzz Aldrin
still kickin unbelievable now despite
the pictures and the testimony of
astronauts like this Laura there are
still those who refuse to believe that
the United States ever went to the moon
we never went to the moon let me prove
it to you with 13 reasons why the moon
landing was faked and with the moon
landing faked I don't believe any one
has ever stepped on the moon this all
reminded me of a day back in 2002 when a
militant moon-landing deniers bart
sibrel hounded Buzz Aldrin outside of a
hotel and well this is what happened why
don't you swear on the Bible that you
walked on the moon you're the one who
said you walked on the moon when you
didn't call the kettle black if ever
thought of saying this
away from me you're a coward and a liar
and a thief ultra popped into the mouth
that is the first time an astronaut sent
a layman to the moon without rocket
propulsion that's one small swak for
Humanity Deena Sinatra sing this today
is an astronaut well fly me to the book
kind of became the unmentioned theme of
this entire landing and he in Houston in
1969 here the mission actress saying
at an event commemorating by the way
that denier Seibel he tried to get press
charges against Buzz Aldrin the judge
threw them out I interviews I
interviewed the first female chief
flight director at NASA on my podcast
the other day Holly ridings she is
really cool she she told me her whole
life story about how she got into you
know NASA and how she became fascinated
with space and the people behind NASA in
our original moon landing and all the
engineering that went behind it they are
the I think of the astronauts and
they're amazing but the unsung heroes
are the people in the early 1960s who
are like doing hand calculations during
the propulsion calculate have to get to
the actor Chris Pratt who is getting
razzed over this picture that surfaced
of him wearing a t-shirt emblazoned with
an historic American flag yahoo
published a story Laura based on six
Twitter postings some charging that
Pratt was wearing a white supremacism
now this is the don't tread on me flag
this is the Gadson flag created by
Christopher Gadsden in night in 1775 it
was a symbol of liberty and freedom and
these attacking Pratt they're claiming
it's a symbol of white supremacist now
just because some white supremacist
might have you use this flag why are we
allowing our symbols this one attached
to Ben Franklin right to be taken from
another question why why can't we then
say they auntie face masks right remind
us of domestic terrorism or some
troopers and stormtroopers and evil
forces and we never want to see them
again like they always play this game
with American symbols but the ante for
people they can do whatever they want
this assume this is gonna this is gonna
knock
just to tie this all together Betsy
Ross's flag is out
the Gadson flight we can no longer fly
the Smithsonian this week asked Kathy
Griffin to donate the blue dress she
wore in this infamous photo holding up
the fake decapitated head of the
president so we're going to preserve her
blue dress but throw out the flag under
which our men marched in to revolution
and created a country I don't know where
now but that goes into the Smithsonian
I'll never walk into the American I have
a question do they have just a blue
dress exhibit with Monica's and Kathy
Griffin I don't know Col Monica Lewinsky
see if they asked for her that can go
next to the red ruby slippers I have a
whole color thing wonderful dress
they're all American dresses and the
ladies award disturbing flag flies
proudly at the Ingram household every
day since I moved and never took it down
I gotta get a new one soon it's getting
faded Raymond thanks so much